I killed the hero,
manipulated the government even though I wasn't even a hero, and
Leland was defeated by my power. Do you know why? The
answer is simple. I am the strongest force that surpasses magical power. I'm a
user of plump power. Even
plump futons
are better.
Hey, I didn't think I was going to do anything with a lie like this. It's just a way to buy
time. Even if I continue like this,
my victory is certain, but
if I return the residents to their normal state now, I'll forfeit their lives. The
wielder of Whip and Power is merciful.  It's true
that you don't know what's going on. It's
not a wise choice to go into battle without thinking about it. You can decide whether to pull back or not,
but wait until that wall is destroyed. It's not too
late. You're powerful, and you
can't measure it by your magic level.  Sadaba:
If you don't have magical power, you can control even that government with ease.I
painted it.If you
use your work, you
don't need it.I'll show you my strength, which can't be measured by magical power level.Hana,
we have another friend.  He didn't seem to notice that I was there. I should have
asked the mayor to take other action. He did
n't want to see Margrid naked, so he
just told me to go and get a magician.
Music]
The power to control the instincts of men who are attracted to their thighs